- Québec donne une poussée
de plus à l'avion A220 d'Airbus,
autrefois la C Series.
FRANCOIS LEGAULT
- Il va s'investir à Mirabel
1,2 milliard US,
donc c'est toute une annonce!
- La province injectera
300 millions de dollars
américains dans la société
en commandite Airbus Canada.
Le transporteur, pour sa
insuffle 900 millions $.
Et Québec s'est assuré d'obtenir
une garantie du maintien des
2500 emplois actuels à l'usine
de Mirabel.
- Si jamais, pire scénario,
il n'y a aucun emploi de créé
pendant x x x x prochaines
années à Mirabel,
le gouvernement du Québec va
pouvoir exiger que la compagnie
mère, Airbus, rachète
le placement à 300 millions US.
- François Legault voulait
éviter le même scénario
qu'avec la C Series,
alors que le gouenenenenent de
Philippe Couillard avait injecté
un milliard de dollars
américains en 2015.
Un investissement qui ne vaut
plus un cent aujourd'hui
depuis la vente de l'appareil
de Bombardier à Airbus.
PIERRE FITZGIBBON, ministre de
l'Économie etnononononovation
- Si on n'avait pas réinvesti,
la part du gouvernement
dans l'A220 aurait été
pratiquement éliminée.- Le potee
de l'argent est là.
- Pour cet expert,
il n'y a pas de doute :
Québec a fait le bon choix.
MEHRAN EBRAHIMI, groupe d'études
management entreprises aéronaut.
- Plus on investit,
plus on accélère la production,
plus on va aheheheheheher...
ces commandes-là vont devenir
de l'argent qui entre.
- L'A220 est devenu l'avion
chouchou dans sa catégorie et
le carnet de commandes est
plein. 500 appareils doivent
être assemblés et puis livrés
dans les prochaines années
à des entreprises comme Air
Canada, Air France et Egyptair.
BENOÎT SCHULTZ, président-
directeur général, Airbus Canada
- L'A220 estuiuiuiuiuiui
l'avion dans sa catégorie
qui est le plus économe en
carburant, et donc en émissions.
Donc un grand... c'est un atout
et les compagnies aériennes,
nos clients le voient.
- À Mirabel, où sont assemblés
la plupart de ces avions,
la nouvelle est bien reçue.
- C'est bien pour des emplois et
puis c'est bien pour le futur.
ÉRIC RANCOURT, Asso. machinistes
et travailleurs en aérospatiale
- Un, ça garantit des emplois.
Puis avec cette annonce-là,
Airbus, ils annoncent qu'ils
vont avoir une relation
à long terme avec le Québec.
Avec cet investissement
de cette nature-là, c'est pas
pour s'en aller demain matin
- Airbus Canada souhaite créer
au moins 500 nouveaux emplois
avec cet investissement
et augmencncncncncncnce de
production. L'entreprise
assemble en ce moment
quatre appareils par mois et
veut en assembler une quinzaine.
Ici Jérôme Bergeron,
Radio-Canada, Montréa